okay we have a voicemail number that
number is two one nine two David P you
know I've had people cancel memberships
or stop watching because I took the
wrong political position
I've had people cancel memberships or
stop watching because they don't like
the format of the show or the frequency
with which we produce programming or
whatever I'm not aware of anyone who has
stopped watching the show because they
found out my sexual orientation but it
sounds like that's what we have here
take a listen to this yeah mr. Packard
I'm not a solicitor or anything I don't
get regular viewer I've been watching
you for a while
and I totally thought that you were gay
and I was really liking everything that
you said and I agree with everything but
dude you know I'm gay totally thought
you were gay so you're now kind of
crushed me what I kind of found out that
you weren't so I wish no and maybe I'll
listen maybe I won't but I always had a
high hope that you were yeah thanks a
lot man you're good but well that's a
shame I mean I don't know why it would
be such a district I don't know how it
affects your experience watching or
listening to the show that you thought I
was gay and I'm not and now you're
disappointed but I have actually the
only interesting thing about this is
that right like I don't care doesn't
bother me whether someone miss assesses
my sexual orientation it's really not a
big deal you know I think we all are
making evaluations if people we meet all
the time about different characteristics
really doesn't bother me one bit my
question is why is the show less
interesting if I'm not a gay guy that is
really the question I would like to see
answered sooner than later
we've got a great bonus show for you
today I'm back on the bonus show Pat did
a great job the last few days filling in
for me on the bonus show I will be back
today we will talk about a showdown
about LGBTQ employment rights that is
heading to the Supreme Court we will
talk about a local story here in the
Boston area a National Grid employee has
been fired it was a trumpet wearing a
trump hat who confronted a woman in
nearby Belmont over her bumper stickers
we will also talk about the disturbing
rise of deep fake videos online all of
those
and more on today's bonus show and
remember this weekend
massive membership fun drive if you want
to support the show you want to do it at
the lowest rate of the year we are doing
a 1-day membership special this weekend
people will be notified by email get on
our newsletter at david pakman.com you
will get an email this weekend with a
one-day opportunity to cash in on an
extremely inexpensive membership for the
year